a billionaire radios optimism about the
donald trump presidency seems
short-lived and letter decline Stelio
and Bob Prince Bridgewater's Co CIO
wrote global free trade and free
exchanges of ideas produce efficiencies
synergies and competitions that are
beneficial to the global wealth by
growing whereas protectionism has the
opposite effect
nationalism protectionism and militarism
increased global tensions and the risks
of conflict for these reasons while we
remain open-minded we are increasingly
concerned about the emerging policies of
the Trump administration here with more
details is Bloomberg's hedge fund
reporter Simone Foxman who joins us here
on set this was a pretty quick
about-face we remember the LinkedIn post
right after the election in which he
talked about the magnitude of the
potential seismic shift that would come
with this election what's changed in his
estimation well at that time he talked
about that shift being broadly positive
for business he did mention
protectionism did talk about populism
but at that time you know those things
weren't as concerning to him as they
apparently are now and I think this is
something yours you're seeing across a
lot of Wall Street and and Dalio being
one of the first to come forward with
this is people took Donald Trump
seriously but not literally yes and now
that they're seeing the literal impact
of his policies I think they have to go
back to their research and say did we
miscalculate here well let's have a
listen to something because in Davos
Cerrone Eric Schadt saker's spoke about
the damaging effects of populism with
satalia let's have a listen globalism is
threatened the multinational corporation
is in jeopardy emerging countries are
threatened domestic countries companies
are benefited you know there's a whole
host of those types of things that go on
right those are we the question will be
will the open in this that began in the
1990s with trade agreements and
globalization continue or will it
reverse there we go so what's the upshot
Simone because let's face it these guys
want to make money and he's been doing
pretty well so how do you profit from
this environment well it's certain
sectors and I think different people
have different opinions of exactly which
sectors they see oil generally can
continuing a little higher inflation
rising but I think the concern if you're
a macro thinker like Ray Dalio who's
invested in markets across the world is
you know do us positive policies for us
business positive policies contribute to
sort of a global recession and I think
that's sort of what he's grappling with
now that's certainly what other managers
earlier this week too many managers from
Carlson Capital were said you know said
the same thing if you start a trade war
you know we're gonna see a global
recession very quickly here's somebody
else who was thinking about these issues
at altitude in Davos was George Soros he
sat down with Francine Lockwood called
Donald Trump a con man his performance
last year was not great in comparison to
raid Ollie's house his approach
different well first of all he was a bit
more bearish middle of last year
certainly saw more more problems with
China seeping into the larger Craig the
other horse breaks it as well and and I
think some of the rhetoric has gone very
euphoric not only on the United States
but on on China as well I think there
are not that many people talking about
you know that problem the the just the
fragility of that economy and that could
be another thing that sort of sets a
recession in motion